hi i'm greg sadler i'd like to thank you
for watching my videos and actually this
video itself is something a little bit
new for me
you notice i'm shooting this in a quite
different backdrop uh the city of boston
behind me i'm shooting this one in part
um because i wanted to say thank you to
some of the people that have been
writing in with comments about the the
videos that i've put on youtube so far
and some of the things that people have
been saying are that they get a lot of
use out of
these these videos mainly philosophy
videos some literature and eventually
i'm going to do some religious studies
videos and some new critical thinking
videos as well
and some of these people are lifelong
learners who are
studying on their own outside of an
academic institution
others are people who
are students but they're enrolled in
somebody else's say ethics class or
intro to philosophy class and they find
that these videos
on plato or aristotle or descartes or
whoever help them to understand what's
going on in their class much better
some of them are actually
people who are using my videos to
prepare for
qualifying exams
in other people other countries
educational institutions
so there's there's a lot of people
getting quite a bit of use out of these
videos i'm very happy to see that
a lot of people have been saying too
that they enjoy them and that's that's
gratifying to to find out as well i
enjoy creating them and i'll talk a
little bit about that
in a moment
why that is but i'm i'm happy that it
goes both ways
so i've had a lot of people actually
thanking me not only
in the channel feed itself but also on
particular videos
there's there's not a lot out there on
some of these these authors and thinkers
there's
or what's out there is
fairly old and maybe not in the same
sort of format
i've actually had a lot of people asking
me to produce
different videos uh new series
some people would like me to shoot some
videos having to do with literature and
i'm considering doing something like
that about the books that i love in
particular
maybe not as a philosopher but just you
know and not certainly not as a literary
theorist but just you know telling you
what i like about them
um what what was
said that really struck me
um i'd actually say touched me
was this somebody said you take these
topics seriously and you teach with
great conviction
and love and i think that's
um
maybe the best thing that anybody's ever
said about the way that i i teach
that i teach with not only great
conviction but but love
for you know the topic for
the sheer act of teaching and the
learner
so i that made me think a lot today and
that's why i wanted to shoot this this
video in particular
and so there's three things i
want to say in response
one is that i do love teaching and
that's that's not something that i
actually started with i didn't love
teaching at the beginning quite frankly
but that's changed over time
and i think that had to do less with
um
gaining new information and more with
with a change in perspective
and actually
thinking a bit more about
what my job was and
the people that i was working with and
the value why these techs are actually
valuable not just to me but to them
i really like teaching this stuff the
sort of things that i'm putting on on
youtube i didn't i didn't always get the
opportunity to do that
you know there's there's sometimes what
we call teaching ghettos
where you're stuck
just teaching this particular kind of
class day in and day out and you can't
branch out and do anything else and
youtube made that possible for me to do
a lot more
which is kind of nice but i really like
teaching these great thinkers and the
classic texts some contemporary things
but mostly classic texts
the things that have to do with with
life that
give us more perspective
that introduce us to new ways of seeing
things i mean when you read plato
and you really pay attention to what's
going on there it will change your life
it won't just change your your thoughts
about things it will change the way that
you
you perceive the way that you understand
your relationships with other people the
way that you
see where your own life is going and
that's just one example i mean you can
say that about dostoyevsky you could say
that about saint anselm there's so many
other
great thinkers that are classics for
that reason and i get to teach them so
in some ways it's you know one of the
best jobs
around because i get to
um
i get to sort of
bask in
and reflect some some wisdom from
these these uh
wonderful
thinkers that we have it's too bad it is
a side note seems like we don't actually
have
all the works of some of these thinkers
apparently aristotle wrote dialogues
that rivaled plato's for how well put
together they were it would be nice to
have our hands on those but we don't so
it's nice to get to teach the aristotle
that i that i do
um
i get energy from from my students
and so when
when it's said that i teach with great
conviction and love
i think that some of that is coming from
the material it's not coming from me per
se it's coming from
what it is that i'm teaching and i think
some of it is actually coming from my my
audience the people that i'm engaging
with i know that when i'm in a classroom
and the discussion is going really well
and i can look out in the classroom and
see that students are
grasping what's going on
or i see a student struggling with
something
and we work our way through it
bit by bit and by the end maybe they
don't know everything maybe i don't even
know everything but we were better off
than we were be at at the start of the
class session
um i get a lot of energy from that
and it's a lot like being on stage after
the class is over
i feel that that same sort of
tiredness almost exhaustion that that
actors talk about after they do a
performance but it's not it's not so
much performing it's more
this is kind of a new agey way of
talking about it and i don't really buy
into a lot of that but it's almost like
channeling you know you're giving voice
to plato or to
thomas aquinas or to thomas hobbs or
whoever
and letting the students actually get to
encounter them
and i think that
i also do get some energy and some of
that that conviction
from my own enthusiasm
as a student
getting to go back to these texts over
and over and over again and get more out
of them each time i'm teaching plato's
republic next week and i know reading
through it i found yet another thing
that i didn't see the last time around
or the last you know time before that or
going all the way back 20 years
so that's very exciting for me
so that's one thing the other thing
another thing that i want to talk about
is just youtube itself this is this is a
great opportunity
for me in particular
i get to teach a lot of things that i
wouldn't ordinarily get to to teach
and
people get to watch it and
gain some benefit from it
i mean some of the things that i have
our course lecture videos but now i'm
doing things on existentialism i've
never gotten to teach a class
directly on existentialism as such and i
even when i got to teach classes that
had some of that those components they
were stuck in the 16 or 15 week format
and you can only pack so much into the
semester with youtube if i want to shoot
40 videos like i'm thinking about for
the existentialism series 40 hours of
actual
video
i can do that if i wanted to shoot 120
hours
i could do that i mean i don't know if
anyone would watch all of that but
certainly people would watch portions of
it and
i get to decide that so if i want to
shoot a course sequence
just dealing with one of the thinkers
i'm particularly interested in
saint anselm
where would you get to teach a course on
saint anselm just saying handsome
you'd probably have to be in a graduate
faculty somewhere and then you might
have five students attending the class
with this i can
put together and teach and assemble
materials and
get feedback from
people for the things that i'm teaching
as i'm doing it as you know as i'm
developing these videos and as we're
uploading them and editing them
and that's really
amazing i mean just 10 years ago
we couldn't really do that
back when i was a
a student this wasn't even really
thought of
when i was a
undergraduate i mean not not a graduate
student
the other thing that i really like about
youtube is is it offers me the chance
to reach
a vast audience
anybody who is interested in saint
anselm and starts googling
um saint anselm maybe not just the
ontological argument but let's say saint
anselm
and
why why god became man or what is the
will or something like that now i've got
a video on that and it pops up
and then they can see it
and you know they can decide whether
they want to watch it or not and if they
do watch it and they get bored they can
always leave
and
if they like it they they stay and they
they comment and they ask for for more
so
this is a really
great opportunity which of course i
didn't i didn't build i'm not
responsible for we're just using the
medium that's there but i'm very
thankful for it
and the last thing i want to talk about
is sort of a little story
very short i could tell a longer version
some other time
about something that happened in my
career and why i
developed the attitude towards
education and students and doing this
kind of
beginning an intermediary level stuff
when i was a graduate student
i had the intention of becoming you know
one of these these great researchers and
scholars and getting a graduate position
and teaching
um the people who would be you know
going out and
becoming philosophy professors
themselves and that meant i would never
really have to teach intro to philosophy
again or ethics or critical thinking or
you know eventually world religions or
any of these things that we call survey
classes
um
and
you know why did i want to do that well
in part it was i wanted to teach the
stuff that's really high level because
then i get to delve into what is plato
saying in this passage and how does it
tie in with all these other works and
that's a lot of fun
and i do do that in my scholarship
i go to conferences and talk with other
plato scholars about that or talk with
other ansem scholars
but that's not where most students are
and
you have to begin where people actually
are
and i think that for
you know a good portion of my
early career as a professor
i didn't avoid them because i couldn't
but i i didn't um i wasn't as
comfortable with teaching these survey
classes what we call service classes not
just survey classes but service classes
where
you're teaching people who have no
intention of majoring in philosophy
they're core classes
where you have to figure out how to make
this material
click for them how to reach them
when they don't have any of the basic
background
and at first i kind of resented that
and i think a lot of professors do a lot
of younger professors especially right
out of graduate school when you're doing
the high level you know
spending time with plato or hegel or
whoever it is all the time
but that's our job
that's our
that's where we actually have some sort
of public presence where philosophy
intersects with the world
i mean socrates didn't didn't say to
anybody you know unless you've had the
advanced classes i really don't want to
talk to you he started with anybody and
he'd talk with him anywhere
on just about any occasion
that actually kind of irritated some of
his followers
um but if he's a model
then we ought to think about service
classes a bit differently
and so i look at what i'm doing here
is sort of the best of both worlds i
mean if i want to teach something
on say nietzsche and i want to look at
the birth of tragedy i get to talk about
whatever i want to
and i can go into as much detail as i
want
uh or or not but i find myself
now with the way i feel about doing this
kind of work i find myself kind of
naturally
thinking about well how what does
somebody need to know in order to make
sense of this what what do i need to
call their attention to
what dots do i need to connect
and i get a lot out of that myself
in part because
and this is this is where i'm going to
end i think that you never really know a
text or a thinker until you have to
teach it to people who've never seen
that before
it's easy to teach plato to plato
scholars and it's easy to teach plato to
uh upper-level philosophy students
it's really hard to teach plato to the
people who say plato who who's a
socrates guy what's going on here
but that's the more rewarding
type of teaching ultimately and so
that's that's what i've been doing in
these videos and uh
seems to be getting some sort of
traction so
i'd like to say to all those people who
are saying thanks to me i'd like to say
uh thanks to you
and
thanks to you for for watching